what neon atronics does we work with a
lab that regenerates the esophagus this
is kind of interesting because this was
by chance but I had a Safa GL cancer I
was lucky enough and had good enough
oncologists and scientists working on my
case that I recovered from it but it's
an incredibly deadly form of cancer with
regenerative medicine you're able to
actually take out part of the esophagus
and replace it with a bio scaffold and
seed that with stem cells so that it can
regrow a new scaffold this has been
known for a long time has even been
tried but without the ability to know
the exact pore size and the density of
how those cells will react to each other
so in other words to have nano scale
resolution it's only an idea it's only a
theoretical idea now this is something
that's a reality this should be also
applicable to any regenerative processes
like this full complicated organs are
already being recreated what makes it
into the mainstream as a matter of
regulation it's a matter of politics
it's a matter of things that are outside
of science but we do hope that enabling
it in many labs for a point that
everybody can try it out will help this
adoption happen quicker so five years is
absolutely a technological reality we'll
see if it's a political reality there
are of course political hurdles in doing
anything in medicine but there that is
also kind of an excuse for us when we
don't accomplish things as fast as we
would like to they are real but I think
the biggest hurdle in nanotechnology and
regenerative medicine specifically is
that the public doesn't know about it so
it's not on the radar of most people so
they're not excited about it they don't
push for it they don't spend money on it
they don't lobby for it they don't
realize that their lives and their
parents lives and the children's lives
could be saved by it it's always amazing
to me the
types of technology that get attention
while others that are truly
world-changing don't get any attention
at all regenerative medicine is a good
example of that